Apple presents events at the Apple store
please welcome this evening's guest
moderator mind body green founder Jason
Wacha in tonight's panel how's everyone
doing we're in for a treat tonight we've
got I think the finest people and
wellness here I'll do brief
introductions to my left we've got
charlie Knowles what I think is the best
meditation teacher in the world give it
a give a hand for Charlie we've got
endurance athlete and plant-based ultra
man rich roll
we've got plant-based chef and healer
and musician and Julie does everything
Julie pie it and then if you don't know
who Tyra Styles is I don't know where
you live and then we've got the
co-founder of and then we've got the
co-founder of stralla yoga Michael
Taylor we're wearing the same shirt so
what's interesting about this group
we're talking about wellness and
innovation here we've all come to it in
in different ways at different points in
our life and we've been able to make
careers of it we're going to touch about
touch touch a number of points and how
that happened so I'm gonna I'm gonna
start all the way to the to the far left
Michael can you tell people about how
you came to wellness and and how you
made it a career you I know you started
out your Harvard doctor startups and
then who you are yoga star thanks Jason
and thanks ample for having us here I
intended to be a doctor that was always
my interest I wanted to and I did I
studied medicine I studied both Western
and Eastern medicine and as I was
growing up I found myself spending a lot
of time in a hospital you know for
various parts of my work and then
different parts of members in my family
were you know dealing with cancer and
some other illnesses and I found myself
not really happy about what I saw going
on and it wasn't really exactly sure why
I went off to
study the English medical system at
Oxford and it still wasn't quite right
and then you know I basically ended up
pulling over to the side of the road and
sitting on a fence for a while when it
came to how to practice medicine in a
way that I wanted to and then Tara
started doing all this stuff with
stralla and before you knew it there
were people sending us messages from
everywhere around the world who were
curing themselves fixing themselves of
all kinds of things that were simply
unfixable in the Western medical world
and I thought okay this is my time to
get off the fence and jump right into
this because it was so exciting and
pretty much Tara gave me what I had been
waiting for and so what about you Tara I
know you started at a young age but then
gotten came to yoga and it really
leverage social media - and video can
you talk a little bit about that sure
well I guess the long story short is I'm
a tiny farm town where there's not much
to do and I just found myself basically
in the woods meditating without really
knowing it was meditating and I've
always been a mover I was a dancer as a
kid so I was doing a sort of moving
meditation and I would tell my parents
about my experiences in the woods and
they thought that I was a little bit
crazy and I would see colors and find
them connected to things and and feel
connected to people in nature and my
moms like stop talking about that that's
weird so when I was in a ballet school
in high school and we had yoga on
Fridays for relaxation and I just
remember sitting seeing the yoga teacher
sitting in the front of the room smiling
happy like he had no problems in the
world and I said I think that's what I
was doing in the woods so I went and sat
next to him and I just was sitting there
for a while and super excited and didn't
know what I could do with my life that
was this but just knew I really wanted
to be involved with whatever it was so
in a roundabout way I sort of made it in
my career without really trying to I
kept following my interest and following
my intuition one thing led to another I
started sharing yoga with people and
then having a studio in Mike's apartment
blogging about yoga tweeting about yoga
turned into books and videos and you
know all these kind of things so it was
really a sort of natural happy path for
me so
but it was a lot but but I think what's
important too is you know people think
you're an overnight success you've
worked your ass off for years you know
like in starting at Mike's apartment and
doing you - you know it was one of my
favorite lines is overnight success over
ten years I feel like I've been doing
this all my life and um I mean it's fun
I know I don't feel like I'm working my
ass off or anything I just I feel like
I'm having fun and and getting to do
what I love to do with my life is the
reward I feel like getting more work is
the reward and getting people that
actually want to come take the classes
at the studio is the reward so you know
I feel like a success is being able to
be in sweatpants most of the time and
this is what dressed up for me so come
the Brooklyn and what about Julie can
you share a little bit about your story
and and how in particularly I think your
story around healing and embracing a
plant-based diet is pretty powerful but
um well for me it it's also you know a
continuing evolving journey and also a
very long journey but um you know in the
beginning it was yoga I found yoga and
without a doubt it's a single thing
that's transformed my life more than
anything but then I was always you know
sort of a slim person so I didn't really
have any food issues until I had the
blessing of receiving a cyst in my neck
and it was about the size of a golf ball
in the front and I took that as an
opportunity to connect deeper with
myself and to find a way to heal it on
my own and I did that through the use of
food diet and herbs it's pretty amazing
stuff and how long how that took place
over the course of two years it's about
two or two-and-a-half years Wow process
it's amazing and rich your story you're
you're the eve of your 40th birthday
yeah in a nutshell yeah I mean my sort
of journey into wellness was almost
accidental but precipitated really by a
health crisis I mean I'm four I'm almost
47 now but on the eve of my 40th
birthday I was about 50 pounds heavier
than I am now and
and kind of headed towards a heart
attack and and I had a moment on the
staircase late one night where I had you
know I had to pause walking up a simple
flight of stairs tightness in my chest
and sweat on my brow and and really
feared that I was suffering that I was
in the throes of the beginnings of heart
disease and which runs in my family and
it was a it was kind of an epiphany
moment where I realized I really needed
to make a change and make a change
swiftly and very decisively and that
kind of led me towards plant-based
nutrition and embracing that really has
resolved all of these issues and sent me
on a completely new trajectory and now
you know Here I am at the Apple Store
pontificating about wellness which is
quite ironic you know if you had told me
several years ago that I would be doing
that I would have I would have laughed
at you but it's been nothing short of a
remarkable journey and I can't stress
enough to you how much more control we
all have over our health how we feel our
energy levels and so kind of my message
is all about taking responsibility for
that and taking that power back and
implementing some simple tools and
lessons into your life to improve the
quality of your life amen and Charlie
meditation you've been meditating for
quite some time yeah I have I was really
lucky in that I had two meditation
teachers for parents they were part of
the early wave of hippies who went over
to India to study with the great
Himalayan meditation masters and they
came back and brought that knowledge
back to where I was born in Australia
and started teaching meditation which
wasn't a widely known career path back
in those days still isn't now to be
perfectly honest but so I got to learn
to meditate when I was four years old
and that's so I'm also on the eve of my
my birthday so that's 36 years in in a
few days and so it's 32 years of
meditation you learned when you were 4
when I was 4 yeah and yes I've been
practicing ever since then and when I
was growing up I said to notice you know
in my household that was quite normal
for us to have Indian Swami's coming out
to visit us and hang out with us at our
and and lots of people in robes and
beads and when I got to a certain age
probably around 16 or so I started this
thought that maybe normal people might
like to meditate as well and so I set
out on a course to to think about
becoming a teacher myself and maybe
teaching it in a way that might be a bit
more accessible to people who weren't
gonna necessarily wear the robes and
beads although there's nothing wrong
with robes nothing wrong with robes and
Bates
they don't make them my size yeah and so
so what about everyone else we've all we
all had moments where we discovered
wellness was really powerful we really
liked it when did you decide this is
what I want to do for a career this is
what I want to teach like rich you you
had that moment but it's I'm sure you
you're thinking you just want to get
healthy yeah I mean I think you know for
me it's been a it's been a personal
journey I don't know that there was one
definitive moment where I decided this
was going to be my career path although
I certainly embrace the idea of this as
a mission you know sort of whether that
takes the form of being a career or just
an avocation on the side I mean I'm a
trained lawyer you know practicing law
for a long time but in the last year
I've really stepped into it as more of a
career path and I think that you know
we're at the Apple store and I'm a big
proponent of Apple products and and the
technology really has created the
platform to communicate with people
directly and that provides the ability
to kind of self style and fashion your
own career like if somebody said to me
well what do you do like I'm not sure I
could encapsulate that in one phrase or
word but through all of these kind of
platforms of communication you know
Julie and I together have been able to
call together kind of a way to advocate
in a way that is on a professional level
and and being able to sustain ourselves
in our family doing that and so another
thing that I think is really interesting
we're here at the Apple store we're
talking about you know there's
technology and innovation around and and
you know talking about yoga with you
know Tara and Michael there's this you
know there's this balance we we all use
social media we all use technology it
helps us with our brands it helps us
spread the spread
whatever we're doing spread that message
but we're also about balance and
disconnecting how do you guys do that
successfully can I reconnect exactly
well one cool thing about things I get
to do is hang out with Deepak Chopra a
lot and we did this iPhone app together
and we went on some morning news show to
talk about it and the host of the show
said oh you know Deepak don't you think
that technology is bad and here you are
putting yoga on an iPhone app and isn't
it gonna take people more out of
themselves and we're out of their bodies
and out of their minds and you know put
them inside of this and disconnected and
he said no no no technology is neutral
it's what you do with it that counts so
you know you can use technology to
complain or you know spread hate or
spread rumors or you know hide behind
you know an anonymous blog and you know
just write nasty things or or you can
you know you know he had something where
he said if you put a smiley face and
send that to somebody all the brain
receptors that go off in a positive way
and you know if you're putting a
positive message like everybody here on
this panel does you know that's an email
in your inbox every day at 4 p.m. from
mind body green that's an opportunity to
take a deep breath and connect and read
some positive information that you can
really make a make a change in your life
immediately so I think everybody here's
a great example of doing that and I
think that's sort of the trend now too
and in technology and it can keep going
that way so and if I may and I think
that the the exciting thing about where
we are today with technology is that I
don't think any of this was a career
choice for any of us like it didn't come
from the brain it wasn't some great
marketing idea that we you know conjured
up together or separately I think it's
really about finding your authentic self
whatever that is and then the beauty of
Technology is that you're allowed to use
that then to create your own sustenance
you know and be able to actually thrive
and live and you know even serve as a
living example for others in a positive
way so so for people out there who are
who are you know they have a passion
they how can they turn that into a woman
what advice would you give for someone
who wants to turn their passion into a
career you know we've been we've been
all very fortunate we're all passionate
about wellness we have life-changing
event you know life-changing events or
what we're passionate about what we do
and we've been able to build careers
what advice do you guys give to someone
out there who's maybe passionate about
something else and wants to turn into
career I'll take a swing at that one I
think the thing that really unites all
the people here on the stage is that
we've we all live what we preach I mean
when I look at rich and just see how
incredibly fit he is it's really
inspiring when I see Tara doing her I've
always admired the work she's done there
are there real examples of what they do
and I think sometimes people get a
little bit lost in the whole like you
know social media branding kind of thing
and forget that at the heart of what
they're about is their actual real
passion for what they what they're
interested in and I think if you're as
there's so many different fields
especially looking in in wellness has so
many people who are really suffering
right now who could use real help in so
many different areas and if you just it
doesn't take very long to look around
and see exactly what those things are
you can talk to any one of your friends
and you'll probably find out five or six
different ways that you could be really
helping people in health and wellness
and then just the the trick then is is
to become really good at what you do and
to live it and breathe it and and and
there's never gonna be a moment when
you'll find you know rich digging into a
McDonald's hamburger because he's always
authentic about what he does you know I
saw as a hilarious video that Tara made
kind of parodying some of the the
aspects of yoga I thought was absolutely
hilarious and one of the things she
parodied was a fellow who was try it was
a teacher trying to get into yoga poses
the telling if I may also get into yoga
pose that he couldn't personally do I
think I know who that guy is I'm not
going to mention any names but on but it
was uh it was hilarious and and but
you'd never see Tara like she's which is
a real proponent of what she does and I
think that's that's the key to it is
find your authenticity fine fine
it's you're really passionate about it
and then become excellent at it if you
become really amazing at what you do and
represent it in every moment then
naturally people are going to be drawn
to you and want you won't want to know
what you're about and and then when I
became aware of these people on the
stage you know the first thing I saw was
you know our tweet or a blog or
something I was like oh that person
looks interesting but the second thing
is wow they're amazing at what they do
if you only have the first part not the
second part then it's gonna fall flat
and what's gonna happen is you're very
quickly message how bad you are so make
sure you're doing it the other way
around and the thing I'll add the beauty
of you know what Charlie says if you're
trying to find your authentic self if
you're trying to find what you're
passionate about if you're trying to
connect in a deeper level these people
here what they do can help you do that
if you look at the practices of
meditation mindfulness yoga eating a
more plant-based diet you do all these
things
odds are it's gonna help you get where
you want to go you're gonna feel good
about yourself you're gonna feel more
connected you're gonna feel more open I
think every one I always say if you're
looking to change your life if you're if
you do those three things you're gonna
be in really good shape so it goes
beyond just you know what we're talking
about here I'm practicing it it's it's
it's grabbing something and and it can
help you creatively artistically and any
any which way you're looking to improve
your life Jason can I jump in absolutely
one of the things if you're asking about
what does it take to turn this kind of
passion into a into a business into a
livelihood one of the things I think is
keeping your eyes open because I didn't
realize until over a decade later why I
was sitting on the fence with medicine
and I think what I realized later was I
didn't like that we were all sitting on
the fence with health that science had
really taken over and said now we have
such a micro-level understanding of
human health and disease that all of us
patients we're no longer part of it
anymore we're just gonna go to a doctor
and they're gonna treat us and we don't
have to know what's going on not even be
a part of what's going on and that's a
nice idea but it wasn't working for the
vast majority of people was
working and I didn't really fully see
all of that until I saw the opportunity
to jump off that fence and get back in
and I think people keep saying everyone
here is living it what I see everyone
here living is bringing health back as a
participatory affair it's not something
that we have to observe from the
sidelines while someone who knows better
than us treats us it's actually it's
great science medicine doing miraculous
things every day but we can also do
miraculous things everyone here can do
miraculous things by jumping in and
becoming a participant in our own health
and that's when I say just keep your
eyes open
it's I always wanted to do this as a
career I just didn't think it was
possible and I didn't architect how it
would become possible but when it was in
front of us I saw it and and that's kind
of how I how I got into this so was was
there a specific moment for you cuz I
know you were you know you doctor
startups sort of doing practicing yoga
when did when did you was it was there a
moment or a time you said all right this
is what I want to do I'm ready to put
the rest behind well I started following
her around how did that work out it's
working out pretty well and for for rich
for you while you're going through so
for you guys who don't know rich did
this insane incredible it's called epic
five correct and that's and that's you
did five Iron Man's in less than a week
on five different islands in Hawaii so
you're going through that rich wrote a
terrific book finding ultra you're going
through this incredible journey you go
through all this what you're doing all
this I know you were doing it there were
many reasons why you were you were doing
this in the back here ahead what you're
saying like hey maybe there's something
here for me something here for me in
terms of a profession exactly no I never
beyond just surviving no no no no I mean
when I was doing that it was
about seeing whether I mean sort of kind
of my up my my my operating question was
just how resilient is the human body you
know I'd have used my body for decades
and decades with incredibly poor diet
drugs and alcohol gained a lot of weight
my energy was terrible all these things
and I was able to revive myself by
changing the way that I treated myself
and that led me on a quest to see well
if I can sort of repair my hell through
nutrition just how far can i push it and
an epic five was kind of the ultimate
test of that and answered that question
which is the human body is far more
resilient than you can imagine and that
applies to everybody not that it
everybody's going to go out and do epic
five or want to do some crazy you know
physical challenge like that but that
principle remains the same and I think
in terms of you know the sort of subject
or the theme is career or transitioning
these passions into a vocation and you
know I kind of echo what what Charlie
said in that you know it's easy to look
at all these technological platforms and
say well I'm gonna make a career you
know doing this but the truth is you
can't transmit something you have in God
like that's that's the operating
principle you have to become an expert
or an authority in what it is that you
are speaking to right so that's where
the focus should be and then and then
you can use these platforms to share
that and share it freely in service with
it focus on being of service to other
people and then if you're doing that and
you're coming from that authentic place
I believe that the opportunities arise
you know when the focus is well how am I
gonna make money doing this or you know
what's my career path I think that
that's the wrong focus to have the focus
should always be on service and there's
like a spiritual equation that takes
place when you're in service then you
know things tend to work out that's been
my experience I agree
tarah one of the things you talk a lot
and why I love practicing yoga with you
guys as you talk about practicing ease
and life should be easy and then too
and not you know and that goes beyond
the mat and the business and life etc
can you talk a little bit about your
philosophy and why that's so important
sure I think it's something that we
started seeing along the way you know
you can do yoga like a 10-step person
that's really stressed out and you can
try to get in all these yoga poses and
really try and try and try to achieve
and try to prove but when you come from
that sort of feeling of service that
feeling of you know how can I help
myself how can I help others then all of
a sudden everything does become easy it
doesn't mean that you're lazy and just
you know in the physical sense of yoga
flopping on the floor or applying no
effort at all but you have this very
efficient thing that happens in your
body that leaves up room for your
intuition and your creativity and all
the cocktails in your brain that do all
the things that when we feel Oh amazing
that can happen and when you're tense
and when you're stressed you know your
microtubules in your brain get crossed
and things go haywire and you make bad
decisions and there becomes this you
know in a box feeling and when you have
space around you physically mentally
spiritually that happens and you know
and you have spontaneous moments of joy
of freedom a neat thing I like to
experience at the studio and one of the
qualities I sort of measure in our
guides and our teachers is if somebody
comes out of your class and they say I
feel a sense of freedom or I feel a
sense of space or I feel a sense of ease
then you've really done your job and
your job is that you've made them feel
good and and that's basically all all
I've ever wanted to do is to help people
and help myself feel good so it's that
intention of connecting and expanding
and connecting and expanding and and
really how can I help so I think as far
as a you know creating ease in your life
it is something that anybody can do
whether you're you know in your job now
or in your job you're gonna be in five
years or trying to turn your interest
into business or or just trying to live
a nice life and and having ease having
that sense of space is is really
something we can all do by just regular
practice of meditation and drinking
green juices and eating nice foods and
feeling nice things and allowing
ourselves to action
feel good because it's possible you can
feel good it feels good to feel good it
sounds good to me I know Charlie you
talk a lot about the science of what
happens like when people meditate or
their breathe or can you talk a little
can you explain why why that works why
we feel good yeah sure I mean there's a
lot of changes that happen in your brain
and first of all to understand why how
you'd feel good you have to understand
why it is that you might feel bad first
you know a lot of people are kind of
important yeah people might be walking
around kind of feeling kind of miserable
and you are let's mentioning those
stress is a is a real killer when you
get stressed you you're you get hyper
tension your heart rate speeds up and
your blood vessels contract and you um
you start to sweat a lot and your
digestion gets suppressed your immune
system gets suppressed and that leads to
all sorts of problems and part of the
feeling good is just the relieving of
those symptoms you know when you
meditate or do yoga and you start to
relieve stress yet all of a sudden
you're like oh wow I can actually my
heart feels like it can pump the blood
around my body effectively and that
unfortunately for many people is a
revelation that shouldn't be it should
be something like the things that we're
talking about I think should be so
regular that we we do them all the time
now but then the the the next thing
beyond that just relieving those the
problems of stress is that over time you
know what scientists have found now is
that the brain actually changes in
response to your experiences and so if
you are experiencing that sort of
blissful ease all the time your brain
actually physically changes in response
to that they're part of the brain it's
responsible for stress can actually
become functionally smaller and so it
becomes more difficult for you to
becomes to get stressed in the first
place you don't get stressed out by
minor things anymore it's literally like
a muscle that you're exercising or not
exercising and on on contrast you know
your your your body's being filled with
bliss chemicals that are making you feel
fantastic all the time and your body and
brain adapt to that environment it takes
you know three months or so maybe even
up to a year for you to really set that
pattern in but if you do that regularly
that's what you're going to start to
experience and that will become your
lived reality rather than just a
momentary respite
in a sea of stress you don't get
stressed I know you it's not that you
don't ever get stressed so certainly
things things can still cause you stress
but like the stress is there for
life-threatening situations it's not
there for when your favorite coffee shop
is cash-only and you've turned up with a
credit card only you know you shouldn't
get stressed out by that the things that
sure that are appropriate to get
stressed out as like you know a fire in
the building yeah I'd get stressed in
that situation but I think the threshold
for stress gets becomes a lot higher so
it's only in those situations where
we're you know you want to have that
adrenaline rush to escape from a
negative situation so is there one I
know we've talked about breathing is
there one thing so you're we're waiting
on the we're waiting on line at
Starbucks and we're freaking out what's
one's what's one thing that everyone can
do to help them not freak out yeah I
mean I one of the things I really like
people to do is like this the simplest
breathing exercise the simplest
breathing meditation that you can do and
literally everyone can do this right now
is just to spend a little bit longer on
your outward breath as you do on your
inward breath because your inward breath
is linked to the part of your nervous
system responsible for stress the
outward breath is linked to the part of
nervous system responsible for
relaxation so if you do if you breathe
in for two and out for for sure yeah
that's some but let's give it a try so
so all you do is go and I'll do it with
my fingers because I have to be doing it
while at the same time so breathe in
breathe out
breathe in breathe out
you just spend a little bit longer on
the outward breath just like that it's
all you need to do you can maybe do it
for a few more than that you could maybe
do it for do it for five or six
repetitions of it and just by doing
something as simple as that you can
start to trigger your nervous system to
be more calm
that's the mers most basic is a very
tippy tippy tippy tippy tip of the
iceberg but absolutely it it absolutely
works I feel way better in four to out
four four
yeah in for tulip four for really simple
so as you guys you know in this you know
we're all entrepreneurs in some sense
how do you guys get through those times
when you when you when you've you've hit
a wall and you're like holy crap what am
i doing or if you've had those moments
where maybe you're not ready to give up
but you're just you're starting to
question things
I guess rich wants me to take this one
yeah well when you embrace your
authentic self and you start to live a
life of authenticity the big myth is
that everything's going to be easy so I
think it requires an extreme I call it
extreme faith so I live in in that kind
of world where I have strong convictions
and believe deeply in the divine hand in
this entire play and the connection of
all of us and I think you get tested you
know you really really really get tested
and you know we have a story some of you
know some of that story and I'll just
tell you you don't know all the story
and we've you know we've been on our
knees many times in the last 10 years
and one of the beautiful things about
that process is if you can cultivate
that extreme faith in whatever way is
natural to you you will see that what do
you call it when the little when the
little baby is crawling on
steal the the Popeye cartoon the Popeye
cartoon baby oh that's a very obscure
reference so in this cartoon the baby
crawls and he's just gonna fall like
he's gonna fall off this steel structure
girder
and then just when he's about to fall
something else catches him and you will
start to experience
I'm sure this in your life and the
beauty of that is that it what it does
is there's a friction and it's really
not that comfortable sometimes and
you're really in pain sometimes but
there's something about the alchemy of
transformation that you need that
friction to actually transform and so
when you do arrive in a place of non
judgment and and love and real really
embodying your authentic self you will
have it in your cellular makeup and no
one can ever take that from you and so
there's this beautiful freedom that you
that you earn or you you become it and
so my go-to is extreme faith I like it
we're gonna open it up to questions just
one last thing tomorrow we're actually
launching video courses on mind body
green calm slash courses with these
people we've got if you like what
they've heard check it out can learn
meditation from Charlie yoga from Tara
and Michael and how to eat a more
plant-based diet with rich and Julie and
that's going live tomorrow at my buddy
Green Comm slash courses their video
courses it's incredible these people you
know or come into your home and
literally teach you everything they know
so please check it out but we're gonna
open up the questions now so this
question is from rich hey rich when you
changed your lifestyle did you also have
to change your friends ie to Jessica did
you have to cut out your drinking
buddies and also a second quick question
what's hotter bad water or a New York
City subway platform I was great quite
two-parter did I have to the question
was did I have to change my friends when
I change my lifestyle well certainly
when
when I got sober I had to you know my
friends at that time were what we call
lower companions so I did end up
changing a lot of those friends my good
friends remained with me and in terms of
changing my diet and my lifestyle I
didn't really find that I needed to
change my friends I had a lot more new
friends come into my life with the
people that were my true good friends
prior to that remained might remain my
good friends and you know I'm happy to
talk with you afterwards a little bit
more about that because it's it's been
an interesting you know it's been an
interesting road with that what's hot or
bad water or in New York City I just I
was just in Death Valley last week I was
crewing for an ultra marathon runner a
guy met some of you might have heard of
named Dean Karnazes wrote a book called
ultra marathon man he's very well known
like distance runner and there's a race
that goes through Death Valley in July
called bad water it's a hundred and
thirty five mile running race and I was
there crewing for him I wasn't racing in
the race but I was there to support him
and it was about a hundred and twenty to
twenty five degrees through who's the
day so I think it's a little bit warmer
than a subway platform but it was a dry
heat so the New York City subway
platforms right up there I would say in
July in August hi everybody
um this questions for Tara sorry haven't
speaking in a microphone for a while
what woods what's your favorite place to
do yoga
favorite place to do yoga yes anywhere I
mean we have a nice studio here in New
York which is great because it's just
really convenient for me and we live
literally across the street from here so
I like doing yoga pretty much anywhere I
am I travel a lot so in hotel rooms is
kind of nice and outside and we did this
little video series called yoga anywhere
we just kind of went around and did yoga
and unexpected places it was just fun
on the boats in Central Park was kind of
fun and challenging and you also make a
lot of friends when you do yoga and
unexpected places I started doing yoga
in the airports just for fun and
and people come up to you and they say
oh you know can I join and it's fine you
know so anywhere but yeah maybe airports
yeah I'll go with airports this
questions for all of you do you all eat
a strictly plant-based diet or do some
of you eat other things in your in your
diet
sure I'll start so I used to be about
90% meat ten years ago I ate so much
steak my face is at the palm steakhouse
in Midtown literally that's how much
steak I ate so it was eating about 90%
animal products back then now I'm
probably closer to 85 to 90% plant-based
so I've reversed those numbers for me
which has been hugely beneficial I was
raised a strict vegetarian by my hippie
parents so I was from the age of 0 to 32
ish or so I had never eaten anything
that had previously had a face and then
this weird thing happened I suddenly
like I'd been grossed out by mates I've
been raised very strict like that this
weird thing happened one day where I
just walked past a pasture meat section
and I think at Whole Foods I just with
that that looks delicious and something
just snapped for me and for about a year
I was just obsessed with eating meat I
couldn't get enough of it I was just
like I was something that my body was
craving I was against all of my ethics
and principles but I still kind of went
with it cuz I believe in following your
body whatever it tells you to do and
then that just kind of like a year a
year and a half that just leveled off
and disappeared and now I'm back to
being a virgin so that was weird I'm
Foster um but but yeah I think it's you
know I I'm a really I think I'm a big
believer in not being dogmatic I think
that your body sort of knows best and
and there's lots you know where we there
may be some differing opinions but we
know I think we we are we are on
Devore's and we and we can't eat a very
wide range of foods and still remain
healthy and we just you just kind of
need to follow your intuition and know
what's bad
but I really think that a plant-based
diet is fantastic and certainly the best
for meditation I found the meditation
experiences that I had with for example
were negatively affected by the period
of my life where I was eating lots of
made I so I can confirm that
experimentally I do eat a hundred
percent plant-based diet but I would
also say that I do think it's also
important to not be dogmatic about it
I'm coming up on seven years of eating
this way and it continues to agree with
me but I do think it's important to
listen to your body and to do what's
right for you I happen to think that
that this is a great way of eating and
it certainly changed everything in my
life and for people that are curious
about it I'd encourage all of you to you
know take a look at it and sort of set
aside whatever kind of preconceived
ideas you may or may not have about what
it's like to do that and I would also
sit I would I would add the caveat that
although my my character of my face is
not on the wall at the palm it probably
should be at McDonald's because that's
why I was eating before but but now yeah
I'm all about the plants now I'm a
hundred percent plant-based now I was
inspired by rich role to go vegan but
I've been vegetarian for years I don't
know how many years I don't know 15
years or something like that and but I
was raised in Alaska on hunted meat so I
grew up on moose tacos and caribou stew
and more salmon than anyone should eat
in their entire life but I really feel
for myself I don't like to give myself
any rules I live in a very fluid
experience so I always say that if I
woke up tomorrow and I craved me I would
go find a really pure piece and eat it
with no judgment and I think it's
important in all of your eating that you
do practice a non judgment for yourself
and also for others because everybody is
on their own journey like that ditto
pretty much just it out no I mean I grew
up on a farm so we ate the cows and the
pigs and I never really liked eating
that but I want
just play outside but one day my dad
went over a deer and brought it home he
ate that and I'm just just not happy
about that either so I you know I grew
up having mixed feelings a lot of mixed
feelings you know then moving to New
York from nothing you know it didn't
have very much money at all my pocket
probably a dollar so but you know I
switched to gummy bears and Mountain Dew
and did that for a while and um you know
when I was able to afford the Vitamix
got the Vitamix and pretty much never
looked back so mostly plants although
Mikey eats cookies every once in while
that aren't from the vegan store and
pizza sometimes so I've pretty much been
through all the diets whether it's just
cookies or just vegetables or vegan or
raw or macrobiotic and you know I have
to say probably the most important thing
that everyone's saying here for me is
just listening to your body really
getting to the point where you can tune
in that your body is sending you signals
you hear the signals and you believe
what you're hearing because it's so
valuable when you just go along with
what you feel that's such a valuable
thing to practice and so good for health
overall
and choosing what you eat there was a
really good set of articles that came
out a couple years ago I think it went
through Time magazine and US news and
they all said hey look we have a big
obesity problem around the world
exercise is not going to help people
lose weight but the most important thing
way more than exercise is choosing what
you eat and getting really sensitive to
that and treating yourself as your own
best laboratory so you're all the number
one experts on you nobody will ever know
how you feel better than you do and if
you can bring that approach into your
food you're gonna know exactly what you
ought to eat what works best for you all
the time will you stick with that every
day
mmm you probably have some cookies
sometimes if you're like me but but
you'll know and then from knowing from
that kind of self sensitivity then
you'll be able to always make a choice
everybody I have a quick question for
any of the panelists I do yoga
meditation in the morning
and at the time I feel incredible 30
minutes afterward I feel great
but then I end up getting into my day to
day and I find myself slipping out of
that state losing some of that that I
just worked out in the morning do you
have any tips tricks piece of advice of
how to keep that state how to keep that
that mindset throughout the day when
things do come up when emergencies do
happen any thoughts on that yeah
absolutely
to say about that actually on the yes so
first of all one thing just
philosophically to understand is that
that that is going to happen until until
you've been practicing for quite a long
time you know does that that sort of
euphoric blissful feeling does tend to
last for longer and longer the more you
do it but I really strongly believe and
I've seen this with people that if there
are the people I know you know I live in
California live in you know Santa Monica
with a lot of people who kind of do just
do yoga all the time and just do
meditation all the time I don't believe
you know they trust me they exist I
should say Trust Fund they exist but
they are and uh they and they seem like
really chilled out peaceful calm people
until you know they get they
accidentally eat the non-organic kale
salad and then they flip right out and
there's like that stability and calmness
has never been sort of solidified into
action and I think actually the act of
like bringing that peaceful calm into
your life and seeing how long it can
last for is actually part of the
challenge of actually making it useful
and real and setting it in and that that
fading away process you're like oh it
you know it faded away after like 30
minutes this time and fade away after 40
minutes this time maybe two hours the
next time and it just begins to last it
a little bit long so you know it's not
that you want to sort of go and live in
a cave somewhere I don't think it's what
you're suggesting anyway but you know
you can do little check-ins you can
recall what that feeling was take a
moment like before before when you have
it a second to sit down and remember the
feeling that you had when you had that
really sort of unbounded blissful
feeling during your meditation session
or during a yoga session and just feel
it in your heart and see how far away
that is from the surface level of your
consciousness as soon as you start to do
that you'll notice it's actually not
that far and the more it becomes
established in you the its it becomes
easier and easier when I talk to
long-term meditators like meditating for
a year or more I'll say you know how
long would it take you to feel that's to
just be aware of that you know sort of a
ticklish feeling that you get from you
know really juicy meditation and they
kind of go mmhmm yeah there it is you
know and it's it's really quite close
but it's not that it's but you still
have to put that little bit of a moment
in to just go oh you know actually do
feel good inside you know one that one
of the real advantages of these things
is you find at the locus of happiness
the location of happiness is within you
not out here you know it's not a matter
of getting more things but you actually
have happiness a source of happiness
that is unlimited within you and you can
find it and so you know you already have
these tools you just have to remember
that the part of the process is this
undulation and it will just last for
longer welcome hi this is a question for
Michael and for the whole panel I work
for an organization that's trying to
bring all these wellness practices to
very low income immigrant Latino women
and this is a population that has a lot
of diabetes a lot of obesity and
wondering if you guys ever think about
what it would be like to make this kind
of work more accessible and any you know
any tips or thoughts about how to get
people such as yourself to expand their
audience the people you know beyond
who's sitting here in the Apple storage
Soho thanks that's a great question Tara
in her own quiet way in developing
strong Strela became in the last year
the most
widely practiced style of yoga amongst
kids worldwide so stralla is in 18,000
schools through the Alliance for a
healthier generation along with the
Clinton Foundation and it's doing
exactly what you're talking about and
exactly what you're talking about is so
critical and I think there are a number
of great organizations that can do
exactly that kind of outreach I think
one of the tough things about the
population you're talking about is after
a while if what you're used to is just
practicing not feeling good essentially
foods that don't make me feel good you
do it enough times your body is a great
communicator to you so it's telling you
I don't really like that but if you do
that for years for decades you don't
feel anymore because your body starts to
decide hey look you're not listening to
me so I'm gonna stop speaking so loudly
to you until maybe you get sick and then
the speaking is really loud so I think
the thing that Tara's work with the
Alliance is doing is just trying to get
people to the point where they're
feeling again or maybe feeling for the
first time and then from feeling you
start to feel okay
like like Charlie was saying it seems
like maybe our natural state is actually
feeling good and we obliterate that
sometimes and then our body shuts down
but there are all kinds of ways online
through organizations like the Alliance
for a healthier generation that can
reach people in a way that doesn't have
to cost a lot of money or bring them to
the soho apple store and all the
resources for its the Alliance for
healthier generation they're free
they'll send we did videos for ages K
through 12 and it's myself for yoga and
Billy Blanks does his Tae Bo boxing and
Bob Harper did some more training things
there's a Zumba element too so they have
dance and they have tons of resources
for food as well a lot of these schools
they're finding out they feed the kids
while at school then they go home and
then they eat McDonald's for dinner and
McDonald's for breakfast they come back
so they're teaching the families have
how to cook they're having cooking
classes and having turned in their front
lawn into organic farms for the family
so it's really kind of using all the
resources and any schools can sign up
for this and
and I've asked them to because you know
it's it's great information so they're
just they're sharing it and they're
giving out the videos to whoever wants
them and we have after-school programs
as well so so yeah I think it is
important to reach everybody maybe I was
just gonna say people can start maybe
with apples free podcast yes and I
allowed the common theme with everyone
here is our mission is to make wellness
accessible you know Charlie talks about
you know meditations not a religion and
Tyra and Michael will talk about how you
don't have to be flexible and do yoga to
do yoga and rich and Julie you know will
say you don't have to be an animal
rights activist to eat more plants we're
all here I think there are a lot of
misconceptions about all these things
and I think the common theme between all
of us is to make these practices
accessible we're here to you know not
preach the choir of people in New York
or Santa Monica or Boulder this
lifestyle is for the masses this there's
a massive health care problem this
lifestyle if you're practicing yoga
meditating or eating more plants you're
doing any one of those things you're
gonna get healthier the current system
is broken everyone knows it all these
things are cheap we just need to break
them down and demystify them and make
them available and Jason's also not
being humble and not mentioning the fact
that the website he has mind-body grain
is a fantastic resource for all these
wellness topics for anyone it's free
there's tons of free information on
there these courses that we're about to
launch they're relevant you know they're
not free but they're quite inexpensive
you know and then and there are going to
be we've deliberately tried to make them
as accessible as we could and make it
make us something that could reach out
you know to people who live in in states
other than California and New York which
is you know is quite frankly so far the
kinds of places that can can support
lots of yoga students were spoiled for
choice here in New York or in LA there's
you know if you didn't come to see me or
any of these folks for all their various
skills there's plenty of people who do
the same thing brilliantly that I
respect so much it's not the case if
you're living in some small town
somewhere and we've got one of the
things we've talked about at great
length is that this project that we're
working on
is the thing that we want to be able to
bring that through the internet to bring
that to the masses to bring it to
everyone in the world we'd love it if
people were to take up these courses you
know all over the world I think that's
great
hi Jason my questions for you what led
you to start my body green were you
working in an Associated field before or
did you have a personal experience that
made you do it
sure I had a number of experience it's
over I was a college basketball player I
worked as a trader for five years once I
paid off my college debt I got out of
that and got into startups in the last
startup startup Iran was an organic
cookie company so it's through that
company I really started to pay
attention to ingredients and eating
closer to nature and what we were
putting into our body
I flew incredible mileage that year and
I had really bad back problems I -
extruded discs in my lower back it was
an excruciating pain told I needed back
surgery did not want to get surgery
started practicing yoga yoga completely
healed my back so I was like wow like
this is this practice this this works
also my wife that year started to
revisit spirituality so all these things
were happening and I said wow this you
know having a spiritual practice
incorporating more mindful movement you
know eating organic closer to nature
removing toxins from our body
environment like this is health everyone
has it wrong it's not about weight loss
it's not about you know disease
management it's it's about this
lifestyle and that was how my buddy
green came about and then the lucky to
found two incredible co-founders and
just kind of run with it and we launched
in 2009 and didn't know what the hell we
were doing and you know now we've took
us you know two and a half years to get
a hundred thousand people to come to the
site in the last year and now we're over
4 million so it's been an incredible
journey okay well that's gonna do it
ladies and gentlemen join me in thanking
our panel one more time for coming out
tonight